you might wonder what exactly Thon is
fighting for at this point the Empire
has fallen after all and the first order
is decades away from reaching full
strength why does this chest still fight
for its Legacy after Morgan sends the
night Troopers to hold off Ahsoka Ezra
and Sabine Thon asks her if they realize
that they'll die Morgan claims that they
were honored to make the sacrifice for
the grand Amaral it is for the Empire
the security of our galaxy if you've
read any of Timothy's AR's Thon novels
this line probably Rings true Thon has
always been portrayed as someone who
believes that is necessary in order to
preserve order and security this line is
also likely a reference to a more
specific Galactic threat the Gris gy
first appearing in the Disney cannon in
the novel thron alliances the grisk are
a race of brutal conquerors from the
unknown regions of the main Star Wars
Galaxy thron initially leaves his own
home in the chis ascendancy to seek out
allies against a grisa gmany his search
ultimately leads him to a high station
within the Empire thron's line in the
Ahsoka finale suggests he might still
have this mission in mind